[Música]
está en el supermercado Cuando
alguien estornuda sobre usted el virus
de la gripe entra a los pulmones y llega
a una célula de la pared respiratoria
todo ser del planeta está hecho de
células desde las bacterias unicelulares
hasta la Gigante ballena azul o usted
cada célula Está rodeada de una membrana
celular una capa flexible compuesta por
grasas y proteínas que rodean y protegen
los componentes internos
ese mi permeable o sea deja entrar y
salir ciertas cosas pero bloquea a otras
la membrana está cubierta por pequeños
salientes que tienen funciones como que
las células se adhieran o unirse a los
nutrientes necesarios
los animales y vegetales tienen
membranas los vegetales tienen pared
celular con celulosa rígida que le da
estructura a la planta la célula del
virus que entra a los pulmones es astuta
fingiendo ser amiga se une a un saliente
de la membrana celular la atraviesa y
llega a la célula al entrar el virus la
célula reconoce su error entró un
enemigo también hay unas enzimas que
cortan el virus en pedazos luego envían
uno de los pedazos por la membrana y
advierten a las células vecinas sobre El
Invasor
una célula vecina lo ve y de inmediato
entra en acción tiene que hacer
anticuerpos proteínas que acabarán con
el virus Invasor este proceso empieza en
el núcleo el núcleo contiene nuestro ADN
que le dice a las células como hacer
todo lo necesario para que el cuerpo
funcione una parte de nuestro ADN
contiene instrucciones que les indican a
las células como crear anticuerpos las
enzimas se encuentran la sección
correcta de ADN y crean una copia de
estas instrucciones el ARN mensajero el
ARN mensajero sale del núcleo para
ejecutar sus órdenes el ARN mensajero va
hasta un ribosoma puede haber 10
millones de ribosomas en una célula
humana todos ellos en forma de cinta que
forman el retículo endoplasmático este
ribosoma Lee las instrucciones del
núcleo toma aminoácidos los enlaza uno a
uno y crea un anticuerpo que combatirá
al virus
Pero antes de eso el anticuerpo tiene
que salir de la célula el anticuerpo se
dirige al aparato de Golgi aquí lo
preparan para liberarlo de la célula
encerrado en una burbuja del mismo
material que la membrana celular el
aparato de Golgi también le da
instrucciones al anticuerpo para que
llegue al borde de la célula una vez
allí La burbuja se fusiona con la
membrana celular la célula expulsa el
anticuerpo y se dirige a localizar al
virus los restos de burbujas son
desintegrados por los lisosomas y sus
piezas se reciclan una y otra vez de
donde se obtiene la energía para hacer
esto eso es función de la mitocondria
para producir energía esta toma oxígeno
Por esa razón respiramos y le añade
electrones de la comida para formar
moléculas de agua este proceso Crea una
molécula de energía llamada ATP que la
célula distribuye por sus componentes
para darles energía las células
vegetales crean la energía Mediante los
estos combinan dióxido de carbono y agua
con la energía del Sol y crean oxígeno y
azúcar una forma de energía química
todas las piezas trabajan juntas para
que las cosas funcionen bien como
también lo hacen todas las células son
un montón de células los científicos
estiman que hay unas 37 billones de
ellas
suceden muchas cosas en su cuerpo para
mantenerlos saludable su sistema
inmunitario trabaja las 24 horas del día
para combatir gérmenes potencialmente
mortales Entonces cómo nos enferman los
gérmenes exactamente Explore Cómo se
propagan los gérmenes con este video